your father obviously kirk douglas
everybody loves as well but he passed
away before the pandemic so
what what's the best advice he ever gave
you because i always get nervous about
my kids wanting to be in this industry
i'm happy for them if they want to do it
but i imagine he
might have been a little nervous because
he knew all the ins and out of it out of
it so did he ever give any good advice
yeah he was nervous i think he knows you
know we
we deal with a high high unemployment in
our
in our performance or performers um
yeah i guess the best advice he gave me
i'll have to clean it up a little bit
but he says look you got to do
if you do the best you can you just know
and you walk away from the best you can
and when you walk away you just say it
and uh that's awesome and that was
pretty much it for me you know so i said
just but just know you gave it to give
it your you're full
yeah so he you know he was 103. we lost
him
last year february so yeah it was a good
time you're gonna go it was a good time
he missed all of that
and then i i just just two weeks ago
uh his wife my stepmother and
but ann was my stepmother for 63 years
wow so i've known her very well and she
passed away and i was very very fond of
of
of her step-parents sometimes you know
they get a a
bad rap it could be a thankless job it
could be a thankless job and
you know for those those step parents
both and i had a great stepfather too
and that actually the four of them
my mother and stepfather and kirk and my
stepmother they used to get together the
four of them preferably without the kids
to have a meal they got along you know
really really well
what but i like to put a big plug in
there yeah they they got along
wonderfully wonderfully well enjoyed
each other's companies
and got to complain about the kids so
that was a
a good situation yeah absolutely
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever